mike miner has never lost to the blue
jays he's done quite well against them
in
his career he's 4-0 with a save which he
got with the royals his era is two
lourdes had a couple of hits in the
first game of the series on thursday and
that has crept his average up over the
200 mark still a slow start for guriel
and the 1-0 a swing and a fly ball well
hit deep left center field taylor going
back looking up and it's off the wall
guerrero into score gretchik in behind
him and goriel with a booming two-run
double gives the blue jays an early
two-to-nothing lead now a change up with
a couple of runners on base and when
you're looking on the inside part of the
plate and you see that change up out
over the plate it looks like a meatball
and guriel didn't miss it hitting it
high off the wall in left field to drive
in the game's first two runs
he has really looked comfortable over at
first base and i don't want to mess with
that runner going and a hot shot out to
simeon near second or making espadal
near second flips to beshette and on to
first and they still
turn the double play even with the
runner in motion boy what a play by
espinal he stays with it and has the
presence of mind knowing with that
runner running that he has time to give
it over to beau and looked like bo got
clipped a little bit on the slide by
mary field
papa we called him his nickname
papa yeah oh okay i thought you said pop
up no that's a terrible nickname for a
baseball player
that's deep left field and ben attendee
has room he was looking like he was
setting himself up to jump into
and maybe get his glove over the fence
oh man i thought that was out on contact
and simeon he's got four already
certainly has the power to do that but
you waited on it
kill his glasses
what a what a great invention those are
and then when the ball went into the sun
you'd flip them down
alberto
is
in time with a little help on the
stretch from santana and beau bashette
is over two outstanding play on both
ends right here
a lot of third baseman think they're
going to have to bare handed this is a
sure play here all right look at that
turns his glove back hands it transfers
and santana says oh man don't put me in
the line of that runner and that's one
of the reasons why major league baseball
is testing out the new bigger base
whit turns throws in time
that's a big defensive play and mike
miner got guerrero to swing at a 3-1
pitch that was way out of the strike
zone
[Applause]
[Music]
you want athletes you got him thank you
you know they've played the yankees six
times already they've won four of them
back to the middle
and out at second base oh
no way wow man wow fancy
what a feed
by whitmerfield to the running nikki
lopez haven't seen that one
look at this watch the feed wit
underhinch has to
to nikki lopez there boy there's some
athleticism some great hands some
excellent footwork
they're gonna
challenge and they'll probably win it
still i mean you can't you can't
practice that no you don't i mean that's
just all
instinct and
adjustments and
huh
oh well so they'll take it
royals will
would have loved to double play but
based on where that ball was headed
they'll take the out
i'd like to see the blue jays get on
here and try and scratch out a couple
more runs oh davis he's going to send
one to deep left field off the foul pole
and gone
he didn't scratch out a run he belted
one down the left field line first hit
of the 2021 season for davis three to
nothing blue jays
told you that mike miner has gone to the
mountain without his bread and butter
pitch that's that cutter slider that one
doesn't get in and jd takes advantage of
that smokes that ball down the left
field line and it goes off the foul pole
about halfway up
this isn't important at bat right here
because you mentioned the good eye by
santana he can walk with the best of
them
he's got a great eye got to get that
first one
charges and fires on a chopper towards
the left side of the infield a good play
made by espinal one down santiago
espinal pin over at third base he made
that great play when he got the start
down in dunedin against the angels and
turned to double play
and then made that one look easy now
santana is not the fastest runner but
you got that short hop and you've got a
catch and throw all in the same motion
well when you don't strike out a lot of
batters in the blue chase i wouldn't say
their starting staff is filled with guys
who strike people out you better keep
the ball on the ground and they've done
that this year very effectively one two
and it's strike three called and now
taylor's unhappy thought the ball was
inside
and guccione hearing it from the royals
dugout as matz rings up taylor for the
second out dosha power hitter a couple
of years ago when he had a full season
he had 26 home runs drove in 84 runs but
matt said look i got a three run lead
it's getting late in this game i'm going
to challenge you and make you hit your
way on challenging with a fastball he
still has enough fastball as he fouled
that one back they can change up right
here on the 3-2 and he got him again he
likes to throw it down and away to the
righties but he froze him on the inside
corner with a change
and five hitless innings for stephen
mattis
[Applause]
he is singled and scored and grounded
out
the first pitch swung on hit high in the
air to left field back goes ben intended
it's gone
another home run for guerrero his second
in his many days and it is now four to
nothing for the blue jays
goodness gracious uh the home run that
he hit the other night 456 feet i
believe was off the first pitch also
so he is up there he is seeing the ball
and that is deep and benettine didn't
even have to go chase it he knew it was
gone
since this is a seven inning game
matt still has to go five innings to
qualify for a win in a seven inning game
so he's accomplished that
if he pitches seven innings
and the royals do not score a run he
will be credited
with a shutout but in order to be in the
record books with a no-hitter seven
innings is not enough
and it's going to be down and the royals
have their first hit
and their third base runner
little bronx cheer out here
hit the k
nice you could tell that that ball had
eyes on it man it was dropping
and matz went on to retire the next 12th
that's well hit to left guriel goes back
still back it's over his head the royals
will get their first run
and ben and tendy
has an extra base hit in three
consecutive games
things are contagious we talked about as
soon as the royals get a hit in there
they're gonna start up again that's what
happens this there was a drive and uh lo
the the left fielder guriel jr showing
no respect to ben and tindy playing him
shallow like he's a punching judy hitter
one two again and a swing and a fly ball
left center field this is gonna do it
easily as taylor tracks it back at the
edge of the track davis can jog home and
the blue jays lead five to one
taylor the lead at first vladi playing
off the bag
and the o2 a swing and a ball popped up
left side of the infield
the espinal and that will do it vladimir
guerrero homers again leading the blue
jays offensively jonathan davis hit a
home run stole the base scored a couple
of runs steven matz six very very good
innings again as he picks up the win and
the blue jays take the opening game of
the double-header tabby by a score of
5-1